Я вже давно вважаю що Пані Мар'яна вона
не є ретранслятором бздурів з власної
якоїсь волі вона є своєрідним тестером і
вона є своєрідним ретранслятором певних
ідей які є в офісі президента зрештою
згадати як вона покривала вагnerргейт І
що там витворялося і починаючи від того
що Вона тікала від депутатів опозиції
вона змінювала місце проведення вона
намагалася не допустити від європейської
Солідар і учасників тимчасової слідчої
комісії як перекручувалися факти Як не
були допитані ті чи інші люди тобто я
думаю що це одна з
скажемо так рук які прикривають верхівку
офісу президента час приколів минув
Треба дуже чітко ставити пріоритети якщо
вона дискредитовувала ЗСУ якщо вона
видавала інформацію яка би не мала бути
То значить на цьому має бути крапка і на
її мандаті